[Music]
hello mister expensive hello welcome
teacher we come to ask you 21 questions to get
to know you a little better
what to have for breakfast tea coffee what did you come
to school by car
as soon as you get to school in ten
minutes what do you think when you come in
every morning
to try  offer a
quality class to my students and
positively impact them with everything
you like about the city of bandera its
people are warm collaborating people
bandera is a progressive city with
a constant impetus to overcome you have a
favorite actor ricardo darín who is
you  favorite singer and abel
who is your hero i have 2 my mother and my
father who taught me to be responsible
loyal honest hardworking among other
things and place you and has visited
the men because of your favorite subject
in primary school language and
literature that  you didn't
like her mathematics
how you were like responsible students,
hard-working and supportive with my
classmates
if you liked it  ta eat from the school kiosk so
very
young what time do you leave school at a
quarter past two
and continue working when you get
home
always a teacher is constantly
creating imagining projecting
programming the meeting with his students I
sing what is your young man gardening  I
like plants that makes you feel
proud as a
teacher for having transformed the way of
teaching here at school and for having
given my students the opportunity to see
a little beyond the horizon
what message would he write on the blackboard
to your
students  I can't, it doesn't exist in your vocabulary,
if I had to give your students some advice,
what would it be: to dream, to dream
big, to work day by day to
achieve their dreams, to trust in
themselves in the great potential that exists in
each one of them because  they have everything
to achieve it
and lastly expensive
because being a teacher exists
I think it was born with me I come from a
family of teachers you could say that it
is d  It's in my DNA if they ask me
dearly what I want to be when I grow up,
I answer again that I want to be a
teacher and because basically
working in the classroom with my students makes me very happy